let's talk about Oklahoma oh goodness
let's do it ladies and gentlemen
Oklahoma all here Oklahoma is I guess
it's two states so we have this story
from CNBC for those that aren't familiar
this is a big ruling today and I was
really confused why it wasn't getting
more attention the Supreme Court has
ruled that the eastern half of Oklahoma
is a Native American reservation like
more than half ya escorting the map this
well I got it's a chunk there you go
okay oh wow yeah that's pretty much half
I guess so I think I'm not entirely sure
this is this is just an image I found on
the internet which is supposedly the
original 1866 treaty reservation look at
this little piece of Oklahoma right
there well you're good right there in
that little corner yeah all right you
still you're still under state
jurisdiction that's gonna be stolen by
Kansas and no time right here's the big
challenge depending on what who you ask
well actually for the most part no one's
talking about this yeah well it's being
recovered but I'm on Twitter and I'm
like shouldn't people be saying
something I saw I was it not exploding I
saw tweet from someone saying guys I
know Trump's tax returns and all that
but what about this story and no one
cared so I start I looked it up and I
read it and I just like started I busted
out laughing yeah like my seriously I
was my main segment today's about this
and I was originally gonna talk about
like Joe Biden adopting Bernie's
policies yeah and then I saw this and I
started laughing I'm like the whole
article it's I'm sorry man I'm just
gonna say it
based on what I've read yeah and I've
read multiple articles and I've seen
I've listened to what the Supreme Court
justices have said it sounds like
precedent has been set to dissolve the
u.s. so I agree it's pretty scary the
simplified version of this argument is
that the u.s. never officially dissolved
the Native American reservation of
Oklahoma when they made it a state yeah
Chief Justice Roberts said that's not
true of course they did they made it a
state of course they did so why are
these other justices arguing that it's
still a Native American reservation
based on that precedent you would need
to make sure I assure you right now
every single Native American lawyer is
pulling up every treaty yeah and they're
gonna point to a single word and go BAM
imprecise language yeah so there were 10
other states that warned outworn to the
Supreme Court if you rule in
favor of the Native American tribes the
same thing will happen in all of our
states as well by Hawaii
yeah Hawaii especially I'm shocked
Hawaii is still a thing like it this was
the beginning of the day Hawaii should
have been like on it already like okay
bye so here's here's the important you
know there's depend on who you ask
you'll hear you'll hear something
different the the left the Supreme Court
justices who favored this and the people
who support them whose all of the
liberal judges yeah say no no it's only
about federal it's only about crimes
like that the state is still working
with Tulsa so this is two million
Americans in this territory that are now
living on Native American reservation
this means so much more than anyone is
saying so let me read you the story and
try and figure this out right so they
say the Supreme Court ruled that a huge
swath of the state of Oklahoma is Native
American land for certain purposes
siding with a creek nation man who
challenged his conviction by state
authorities in the territory I'm gonna
be very careful about reading the story
because the guy who won is a diddler not
a good guy not a good guy in 1997 he got
convicted of middling a child a
four-year-old and Gustin argued that his
conviction would not stand because it
was legally Native American territory
and the state had no right to prosecute
and the Supreme Court said yes let the
men go and now the state has said there
are 1700 violent criminals or just
criminals in general that will now have
the same ability the same argument now
now here's the other side of saying
they're saying no no because their
opportunity for appeal and all that has
you know long since passed I don't
believe that if they set a precedent
that this is on you know Native American
land yeah that means they were
unlawfully arrested in the first place
how would you not be able to petition
that exactly well let's read a little
bit
they say the decision means that only
federal authorities no longer state
prosecutors can lodge charges against a
Native Americans who commit serious
alleged crimes on that land which is
home to 1.8 million people of those
people 15% or fewer are Native Americans
quote today we we are asked whether the
land these treaties promised remains and
Indian
servation for purposes of federal
criminal law gorsek wrote because
Congress has not said otherwise we hold
the government to its word now here's
here's here's why I think this is
serious because I understand he's saying
it's about federal criminal law but does
this not open the door now for one
upping that argument and saying if for
criminal purposes why not other purposes
yep more importantly what what did the
state say the state didn't say this is
only about crimes they said it's gonna
affect everything because think about
this he says federal criminal law what
what is the law do what does the law do
collect your taxes you don't pay our
taxes okay what happens if you live in
this Tulsa area and you do not pay your
Oklahoma State tax I'm sorry can they
actually can that can the state come
after you know or is this jurisdiction
is it they say if you're a Native
American so which is only 15 percent of
that but I'm not entirely convinced it
ends here
right so let's say out the descent right
yeah Chief Justice John Roberts
dissented the ruling as did fellow
conservatives Clarence Thomas Samuel
Alito and Brett Kavanaugh in his dissent
Roberts warned that across this vast
area now deemed to be Native American
land the state's ability to prosecute
serious crimes will be hobbled and
decades of past convictions could be
thrown out who know I'll be thrown out
on top of that the court has profoundly
destabilized the governance of eastern
Oklahoma the decision today creates
significant uncertainty for the state's
continuing authority over any area that
touches Indian Affairs ranging from
zoning and taxation to family and
environmental law none of this is
warranted what has gone unquestioned for
a century remains true today a huge
portion of Oklahoma is not a creek
Indian Reservation Congress
disestablished any reservation in a
series of statutes leading up to
Oklahoma statehood at the turn of the
19th century the court reaches the
opposite conclusion
only by disregarding the well settled
approach required bara by our precedents
Republican Oklahoma governor Kevin's
stich said I am aware of the ruling in
McGirt V Oklahoma was handed down this
morning by the Supreme Court my legal
team has been following the case closely
is reviewing the decision carefully they
will advise our team on the cases impact
and what action if any is needed from
our office I'm gonna skip over they talk
about McGirt the state of Oklahoma in
turn argued to the Supreme Court that
the creeks nations claimed territory was
not a reservation at all the state said
that if the Supreme Court accepted
mcgirt's reasoning it would quote cause
the largest judicial abrogation of state
sovereignty in American history leaving
Oklahoma in half in court filings to
support McGirt the Muscogee nation noted
that although that although the tribe
had no role in the genesis of this
litigation it quote now finds its
reservation under direct attack Ria's
kanji an attorney for the tribe wrote in
a filing that Oklahoma was exaggerating
the jurisdictional problems that would
ensue if the state lost its case to the
extent they hold any water the state's
posited consequences stem from the fact
that both executive branch and state
officials actively sought to undermine
Congress's determination that the
nation's government and territory would
endure kanji wrote gorsek endorsed that
argument in Thursday's decision he noted
in the majority opinion that no one
disputes that mr. mcgirt's crimes were
committed on lands described as the
creek reservation in an 1866 treaty and
federal statute but in seeking to defend
the state court judgment below Oklahoma
has put aside whatever procedural
defenses it might have and asked us to
confirm the land once given to the
creeks is no longer a reservation today
gorsek flatly rejected that request by
the state under our Constitution states
have no authority to reduce federal
reservations lying within their borders
just imagine if they did a state could
encroach on the tribal boundaries or
legal rights Congress provided and with
enough time and patience nullify the
promises made in the name of the United
States that would be at odds with the
Constitution which entrusts Congress
with the authority to regulate commerce
with Native Americans and directs that
federal treaties and statutes are the
supreme law of the land he added if that
happened it would also leave tribal
rights in the hands of the very
neighbors who might be least inclined to
respect them khanjan an interview at the
decision said that despite the arguments
by the state and in Roberts dissent I
don't think this case is going to have
an earth going to have earth-shattering
consequences on the residents of the
land by the Native Americans it just
doesn't change anything with respect to
non-indians in terms of criminal cases
well here's the issue I see with this it
definitely changes and this is what you
brought up new lawsuits will emerge well
I believe that's what we'll see you
they don't have representation anymore
the Americans that are now living in
that area no longer have representation
I think they still legally do okay so
they still will have their seats the
Senate seats I don't well the Senate yes
cuz Oklahoma's a state okay but I'm
curious as to how this will affect the
congressional districts right if they've
said this is this is a Native American
reservation now here's what's the
craziest thing about this man we have an
1866 treaty with them right okay I mean
I've got a video showing all of the you
know the territories of the the Indian
homeland the need American homeland and
the reservations and you can clearly see
that we've gotten rid of many of their
reservations and this is the points
bringing up earlier if they're gonna
argue that this 1866 treaty which we
basically you know walked all over is is
still being upheld then why wouldn't any
of these groups then just sue and say oh
we have a treaty - yeah so how many how
many other states are gonna be impacted
by this I don't entirely know I do know
based a lot of the maps the eastern
region is fine there's no reservations
in the eastern region where most of the
European settlers were you know during
the first several hundred years then
after the Revolution from the late
seventeen hundreds throughout the
eighteen hundreds we had westward
expansion manifest destiny things like
that I mean this clearly shows it all
right here yeah so I'll just let this
roll in the background this video calls
it the invasion of America I think it's
kind of funny but there's a couple
questions I have now base on this ruling
I think I think SCOTUS opened the door I
could be wrong I'm not a lawyer man
maybe there may I don't think there'll
be any earth-shattering changes for now
but I think the door has been opened the
changes will slowly emerge exactly so in
the in this video I've pulled up it's
going through the years and showing you
the lands that are blue our slowly
turning gray because they're being taken
by the United States you can see some
reservations pop up here and there but
over time more
Morland is just absorbed into the u.s. a
bunch of reservations pop up in
California and that mid-1850s
so this is literally Americans just
going out there taking the land yep
was there a treaty for any of these
lands that were settled on by Americans
with the Native Americans many of them I
would say no in fact reservations I I
think are let's see a big jump right see
they're also a reservation I mean that
whole state of Oklahoma essentially
except the Panhandle was part right
Muskogee so so take a look here in 2010
they say only this tiny bit just out
just a and the tip of Oklahoma is
reservation now they're saying a whole
you know the eastern portion of it you
know like forty percent I have a
question if that's the case if they're
gonna argue that we have a treaty from
1866 and they say you know the United
States agreed this was your land
therefore will uphold that isn't there
an argument to say okay well we have no
agreement on any of the other land so
that's still ours
it was never yours in the first place
right I guess yeah you could make that
argument yeah well I think that argument
now has much more merit based on the
decision of the Supreme Court if the
Supreme so the way to describe it is
like if you and I if I trade something
with someone and then take it back and
they go to court and say no no we traded
that's mine he agreed they'd look it
over and say well you did agree so give
it back and there'll be a long court
battle let's say I just stole from you
yeah the cops would come and arrest me
and say you stole it give it back like
there's a there's no lawsuit it's a
straight-up theft right so if the
argument is that the US must uphold its
contracts and that if the land was
granted to them it's theirs well their
argument as this land has always been
ours there was never a treaty signed so
you're on our land right I see why why
wouldn't they be able to present those
arguments right they probably have
before and maybe you know they'll keep
trying but the bigger the bigger fear I
guess is that many other states have
warned outright that they have the exact
same issue with reservations in their
states even Maine was saying apparently
like we've we've had native land that
there was a treaty and then you know in
1800 the treaty and now we build our
city over this place
so what's gonna happen what you know you
know there's a
servation apparently in California it's
like one acre one yeah it's like in the
middle of a city or somewhere because
it's a cemetery I guess so there's a lot
of places like this and I see it feels
like the door has been opened so I
question because Oklahoma is part of
Louisiana Purchase
we bought it yeah we didn't exactly make
an agreement as such as far as I know
but we literally purchased it outright
from the French I think right you know
what man I think I know where we're
going we're civil war no no no I sure
but the point I'm making is they're
they're now going to start asserting
this is this this is this is the move
being made and and I think we'll see an
expansion of this an escalation of this
ideology this rhetoric these ideas that
we don't own the land we never bought it
we don't have a right to it they're now
going to say the lands that you
contractually owned based on the
ancestral you know the Native Americans
are these so these are ours and maybe in
50 200 years all this land will be
controlled back California will become
under complete jurisdiction of the
Native American tribes or the SJW
universe yeah well you know and a lot of
a lot of Native Americans are like 132nd
you know Native American okay because of
just time settlement European
colonialism whatever but it seems like
the doors been opened to now they're
gonna start arguing
you're on stolen land decolonize like
this is step one maybe it stops here
yeah but I'll throw it back to you know
good old John Oliver when Donald Trump
says they're gonna tear down the
Confederates where does it end
Jefferson Washington and John Oliver
said somewhere it stops somewhere
obviously they're tearing down
Confederates not the founding fathers
and then they tore down the founding
fathers yep so where does this stop now
we're gonna see main Texas Montana all
these other states that were warning
Hawaii Hawaii is the best example
exactly that's right because so several
years ago I think it was maybe like six
seven years ago I don't know it's
evening Google search this a bunch of
Native Hawaiians stormed like the state
capitol building and and barricaded
themselves inside it like armed I guess
for like two weeks something like that
happened it's been a really long time so
one good
it was the original chess the original
chess well I mean no it's well I mean
Hawaii had a king and everything well
actually and that brings up a good point
isn't like the entire history of humans
conquest people taking other people's
land yep right there's a there's a song
I think it's called this land is my land
uh-huh there's a it's like a very famous
viral video well the next line is this
land is your land no oh this land is my
land God gave this land to me oh I
didn't hear and the video he's talking
about it's talking about Israel and it
starts with all the different nations
that have laid claim to the holy land
and fighting the bodies keep piling up
where they keep saying this land is my
land God gave it to me okay yeah but
what were we talking about before that
did you uh it's an old story and so
somebody emailed me this saying that
Hawaii was essentially you know occupied
and taken over yeah that America needed
the strategic position in the Pacific
and so they broke a lot of rules to make
Hawaii you know into a state and they're
Native Hawaiians who have always
resisted and never agreed to this
so do we have a hard treaty with the
people of Hawaii over this state
becoming I don't know much about this
kind of stuff I mean I'd like to do some
digging on it you can't find anything on
it I can't find anything that far back
it was I think it was during occupy wall
street which is why it was like a big
deal everybody
yeah the Native Americans were like
demanding their land back the Native
Hawaiians we're gonna demanding the road
back so occupy Honolulu in 2012 I don't
know it sounds about the right time yeah
that is the right timeframe well I don't
know exactly what happened but they like
storm into the Capitol building or
something yeah there there you go camped
outside the Capitol building no no
inside Oh inside maybe maybe that was it
I don't know but apparently it's
happened multiple times I guess like
Hawaiians being like give us back our
land and now it's occupied by big
businesses and the military and you know
and America its American now so what
happens if a lawsuit is is with wage
saying that they have no jurisdiction
over this and they say that you know the
original agreements for statehood were
not in more imprecise and then you get
these same justices going yep there
because I've already set the precedent
themselves I don't know maybe maybe it's
all overhyped you know it's possible my
only my only issue with it is
considering how insane everything has
been this year I'm gonna bet on the
worse the worst of us you know they got
a volcano sharks now you see the story
cuz I what I'm sorry voce no sharks yeah
well I mean about the edge of my seat
don't leave me hanging tomorrow I was a
viral post on reddit oh that's a they
found ya they live inside a volcano is
that right like swimming through the
live inside a volcano this is from 2017
it's not sharknado but it's definitely
shark Kane oh okay thriving active
sharks and underwater volcano in the
solar oh okay it's it's endured stay
still a living water yeah this year
that's not as just when you I don't care
anymore
I wanted lava sharks they're made of
like some extremely dense metal it
doesn't melt or something yeah sick 2020
has not yet we have not reached the
crescendo man
no it's oh you you can hear the I feel
like you know the horns just just yeah
yeah you know like boom no don't just
came in the cannons yeah literally
cannons in that song
they found live sharks inside an active
volcano and in January oh yeah is out
you're talking about I guess so I hadn't
seen that oh man yeah there's only one
thing any of us could do at this point
what's that smash that like button oak
it from you
that's right unknown so I said as long
as they're smashed in the like button
and subscribe well I won't be upset and
we will read super chest sir I saw the
point but let's let's get let's care in
this conversation man I want to talk to
you guys about
you know kind of like the end of America
huh
great so it's an election year mm-hmm
the Democrats seem more desperate than
they've ever seemed yep been saying that
there's there's a a couple polls have
come out predicting a Donald Trump
victory but for every poll or or
forecast model that says Trump will win
there's like seven that say he'll lose I
know it's true but there's another one
that came out I was talking with this
earlier that says the riots are helping
Trump dramatically as we you know and
they said that when polled it was like
71% of people said they prefer all lives
matter to black lives matter yeah so
that's a that's a huge swing but we have
heard similar things from two other
polls economists in YouGov showing that
most people in this country have a
positive view of all lives matter mm-hmm
and not a pot and it's like 40-something
percent have a positive view of black
lives matter yeah so but that makes
sense though because most as we talked
about earlier most people are not
racists most people do believe all lives
matter and and the black lives matter
movement you know it it's kind of like I
mean what Terry Crews was saying we get
we got to have it be black lives matter
not black lives better and it's like
they're trying to convince more people
like the people that do believe all
lives matter it's like they're trying to
convince people that no no no you're
racist black lives matter means like if
you don't believe this because they
counter with all I've matter which you
made a great point the other day the
only thing you can say to it is yeah
you're absolutely right they do because
it's true don't like you know you you
have to you have to understand like if
they if they truly feel that black lives
don't matter then you have to that when
they say it you you there's only one
thing to say you're absolutely right I
think you're absolutely right they
matter
absolutely 100% they matter the problem
is it's like III you know their argument
is all lives matter as a rebuttal right
exactly
racist and it's like it diminishes what
they're saying and I'm like why do you
assume negativity exactly if I said if I
said black lives matter and then someone
was like all lives matter I'd like they
do thank you mm-hmm how's it going right
I'm not gonna matter
no you made a really good point there
it's it's there assuming that if you're
not on in their party in their group and
you don't agree to their ideology you
must be on the other side of the
spectrum a hundred percent there's no
there's no little bit no no negotiating
but they're just this or you're my enemy
now but there are people who get really
angry at people saying black lives
matter I I see that also I'm sure if
someone came to me and they were like
but in my same reason if someone's like
I got a flat tire in my car I'd be like
let me what you need and if someone else
came by and said well what about all the
other cars I have flat tires you can
help them too I'd be like I'll see what
I can do yeah yeah thanks for bringing
it up I don't know I'm not gonna get mad
about it did I get it I I'm having an
effect on you you're starting to get a
little more positive I feeling I feel
that's the milquetoast fence-sitter you
know that's pretty that's pretty
positive bro what then I'm then I'm not
gonna but that's it that's how I that's
that's my shtick that like both sides
come to me and I'm sitting there in the
middle going like whoa whoa hey hey whoa
whoa don't cross over this fence I'm
sitting here well my perspective is
always the one of optimism so I sense it
it's it start the level is raising
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you